but now I hiked on Friday I did eight
miles in Santa Monica I went to the
canyon Santa Monica I did eight my house
- in the woods - meet as Blount its
policy told me about this and I'd like
to I'd like to hear this I'd like to
talk about this well I have been really
cute over you with anybody nope okay I
was really ketogenic yeah I've been on
keto diet yeah I drank a ton of coffee
and I got up early to drive down there
sure I dropped that morning poo not that
morning you know I'm saying a crop
morning big problem a true poet so I had
to stand up in the night and horror
Thursday night I thought yeah I came
home wife he had you pull a for me
waiting oh so I'd say it's 9:00 it's
12:00 12:30 sir a huge pin usually I
don't eat them but you know a lot of hot
sauce is all kiito's just chicken
guacamole you know you got a [ __ ] now
it's like that went to sleep Papa with
sleep yeah Pub wakes up right I don't
know let's say six cups of coffee before
I go that's good that's good
I'm halfway through this hike some fans
recognize me Oh picture yeah no problem
hmm tell me it's and I go oh my god I
have to try well this hurts yeah and I'm
gonna power through this cuz you guys
are behind me so I'm parents are trying
to show I'm a leader you know I'm
[ __ ] going sweat Maya it's hot I'm
sweating two miles in it's hurting so
bad I do I can't I'm telling you I grab
a tree like this the guys go you are I
brought you I'm good and I'm kind but a
little dehydrate em up you boys go ahead
gotta go ahead
they wanna head Scout on top of that
mountain yeah I don't see anyone come
for a little while in a while but they
are coming yeah I have to drop trou
right there dude can you squat or do you
not know how to squat no I squat you
thought you taught me that many moons
ago yeah I squatted yeah but I went in I
went into Jumanji now I gotta go ahead
and go now wait peer deep in the Horde
and where I'm like oh that's for sure my
little red riding-hood got lost
I'm talking snakes whatever but it's
worth it cuz if I don't release this
inner ol in me I'm gonna die yeah I
spray-painted that entire tree Brown you
could throw that tree away you throw it
away so here's the thing animals avoid
that for the next week here's thing I
don't know poison ivy I'm not an expert
so I'm like I'm not wiping my ass with
these leaves no so I keep it going
oh yeah mud butt so I keep it going that
movin has every lady follower but
whatever could you would I got my butt
so I'm still going you gotta take your
underwear off or your and use your shirt
or something I thought about that it's
war you know me I'm self-consciously my
shirt I'm rather have mud but uh so I
keep going get body dysmorphic yeah so I
keep going right another mile old dr.
diary hits again going nah we ain't done
bro yep now uh uh I hear a guy go
there's a waterfall down there I go how
much on this waterfall [ __ ] all over
yeah and they just wash my shirt that's
where I'm at right now so just move your
ass I've seen Bear Grylls
yeah I've seen survivor man I'm on that
level right now yeah so I'm like perfect
so I I'm mentally I might just keep it
tight to get that waterfall then wanna
[ __ ] everywhere dude the thing gets
turtle you got it the whole time you got
I can't walk around with it with a dirty
whistle dude I can't do it I'm Smuts wet
I'm sweating and you got poo and then I
got short Reebok I'm thought oh you got
shorts on yeah yeah yeah so I'm team it
time you can stain them up here stayed
them up I'm just trying to this
waterfall your boy gets the waterfall
that's [ __ ] Navy SEAL mental toughness
I get to the waterfall what do you think
happened everybody's there no no one's
there there's no water it's a dry water
you know I've we're in Los Angeles
hasn't rain there's a bigger team not
gonna work now there's still some kids
on the tube or whatever like swinging
from like all right uh-huh
so I went behind the tree again and
[ __ ] painted it brown oh boy then I
hit the road and then so you walked all
the way back with with a with a miles a
miles with your poor [ __ ] your poor
whistle must be of all kinds of
irritated I was fine take a look at it
all right pick a spot on the wall let's
peel that peach and see what's going on
dude what a disaster late night Chipotle
ketogenic diet you mix that with a
little coffee this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
thank you